nearly a decade ago yow's brother walked
the length of this speech after arguing
with his mother but he never returned he
points to the direction that Vera misto
took where he ended up Crossing into
Gaza and then captured by Hamas aa's
mental health had deteriorated not long
before that the death of his sibling
deeply affected him and now his family
say the wait for action has taken far
too long this sh
9 years we're living but we're not alive
it's a bad dream that's been going on
for so many years we can't cope we're
asking the government to bring him home
like it should all
citizens all this time they weren't sure
if AA was dead then Hamas released a
video earlier this year showing him
alive well we've only been here for a
few minutes but every few seconds we
hear loud fuds and that's the continuous
bombing of Gaza that's happening just a
few few kilometers down this Coastline
over here now Yow tells us that every
time he hears those thuds he thinks how
terrifying it must be for his brother
Israel's air strikes have further
complicated things but with more
captives now held in Gaza aa's relatives
hope he'll be freed if a ceasefire deal
resumes his family says neither the
Israeli War cab or those leading to
bring them back home campaign have
contacted them leaving aa's Community
with no choice they say but to raise
awareness to his case alone so this is
AA mial has been painting AA and his
family for
years and his mother she's
crying now she aims for her art to bring
his name back to the public domain after
years of being
forgotten his case she says has
highlighted the inequality that the
Jewish Israeli Ethiopian Community faces
as well as that face by the Arab bedin
minority after hish was captured in
2015 at first his pictures and his Shams
were not present in the Square after
pressure his picture was finally printed
the authorities gave up on AA they
didn't include him in a captive exchange
deal a few years ago they say that
people relate most to those that look
like
them mial says she doesn't want him to
be stigma TI because of his mental
health that led him into Gaza she says
it could have happened to anyone so
she'll continue to campaign for his
release in ashalon Yow says AA will have
experienced a number of wars on Gaza but
he prays that this will be the last and
one that ends with his brother's safe
return s Al jazer
ashalon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
zero